let's see if we can write 0.072 seven as
a fraction now let's just think about
what places these are in this is in the
tenths place tents this is in the
hundreds place hundreds hundreds place
this two is in the thousands place
thousands and this seven right here this
last seven is in the ten thousands place
ten thousands so there's a couple of
ways we can do this the way I like to
think of this this term right over in
the ten thousands place we can view this
whole thing right over here 727 ten
thousands because this is the smallest
term or the smallest place right over
here
so let's just rewrite it this is equal
to 727 over 10,000 over 10,000 and we've
already written it as a fraction and I
think that's about as simplified as we
can get this number up here is not
divisible by two it's not divisible by
five in fact it's not divisible by three
which means it would be divisible by six
or nine doesn't even look to see you two
seem to be divisible by seven it might
be a prime number but I think we are
done